le monde culturel est bien sûr très
fortement impacté 72 % de pertes de
recettes pour le spectacle vivant le
patrimoine c'est 36% 31% pour les arts
visuels
il faut savoir que 61 % des recettes du
secteur culturel sont réalisés en ile de
france alors la situation perdure avec
cette deuxième vague la région a choisi
de maintenir les aides d'urgence comme
le maintien à 100 % des subventions ou
des aides en contrepartie du maintien de
l'emploi en termes tant ces trois aides
régionales que 8,19 à destination du
secteur culturel seront
exceptionnellement reconduite en 2021
dans le cadre de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire et ils nous préciserons
ultérieurement les modalités d'accès à
ces aides pour accompagner la
digitalisation des commerces transilien
de moins de 10 salariés
la région propose de chèques numérique
qui est une aide de 1500 euros maximum
actuellement le clic une collecte
représente pour des librairies
francilienne entre 15 et 50 % de leur
chiffre d'affaires habituel
la région va aussi amplifier son soutien
en faveur de l'investissement culturel
en 2020 66 millions ont été investis sur
un budget de 120 millions d'euros
le long terme est aussi étudiée par la
région ile-de-france valérie pécresse
prépare un plan état région de 200
millions c'est un plan d'investissement
pluriannuel sur six ans cet
investissement
cet investissement culturel il se
traduit d'ores et déjà par un certain
nombre de projets que nous avons décidé
de soutenir
avant-hier nous avons voté une
subvention exceptionnelle de 5 millions
d'euros pour la modernisation du musée
de l'air et de l'espace du bourget que
dans le cpr enseignement supérieur il y
aura aussi un certain nombre
d'investissements dans les écoles de la
culture un groupe de travail spécifique
est en cours sur la reprise de
l'activité à l'image de l'été culturel
de 2020 la région réfléchit déjà à celui
de 2021